there I only your marine grandson is to see you ask
blocking the team through the bargain
google and today this video shows you
how to implement the slide integrates the
from one to the other with the
continuous feedback that the user can
to see very smooth how is it going
must have seen this our application of
google play good this is the example of how
is that implementation will be where you
can see the indicator is changing from a
leg to the other very smoothly
while you drag there from the other
continuously so you do not have any
the screen appears for an hour to
other
good to start doing this the first
step is the layout
I have it first when I read the theses in
top with slide in tag layout
tap down on the river asks him to go
is basically content in this place
At this point it is important to remember
put the full name past the slide
intab layout ok because this is a class
that will be included in your
code
well after that I have to do a
set up a certain specific order is the
next you will first pick up and get
instance of the river fish and define or
to adapt a possible kiss and then just
the slide integrates layout from our side
also set the river and fish needed
providing the
communication between the two and I have
here or adapt
in this case after what you want but the
that we are seeing here this moment is
To Set A Tahiti Jet Plane Is Important
you also define scale because this
method called whenever it is necessary
set the title of the tag you do not put
That's when I put something wrong.
title of the thesis the name of the land will stay
incorrect
in this case you are only using a title
based on item position had a team
2 and so on
well then you can get those
classes there that you experiment with
make goal I had in the beginning here the video
another personal legal example is this one
today you will notice as you change from
one for another, the indicator is
changing color and it changes during
position and even the message
was red after now yellow
ok and it's possible to make this transaction
very cool way and with the feedback
good continuity, the first people we
definition of some data that I will
use to configure
these tags to configure the tab and
everything else is a title there.
I indicated the triumph of Wagner and indicated
ter is to unify the thesis title and where
will be the separator from one tag to another
ok you can save this shape you
want in another resource in another file
that when you get good access and there
setap is a bit different in this
in case we are using a
other more personal adapter if you have
another care you want to use
What do you already use, there's no problem, the
It is also important to keep the sequence
startup
In this case the late afternoon has a Doppler
that the Colorado team tell me where I'm going
write two meters that the indicator
color jet wagner colo né indicator
will stay in the tag title and I'm
using those data I showed in the
At first I'm doing jet position.
Where are you going?
whose data
just remembering that it will always try to gray
but in case you want to do something
more colorful and that the will is just to change
the position of the colors that you go
achieve a very interesting result
and there adapts it is very precise that they had it
state before the difference is that now
I'm taking the title according to
position also dataset here
instead of doing the kind of agreement with the
position is good, good staff or
complete functional codes
go to the site was address has both
base that the former and how
had cholera if you see how the
color introduction the link will also
be in the description of the video and
Will to test new colors test
new layouts leaves application still
more beautiful
thank you guys until the next